jetzt rufe ich auf die
Tagesordnungspunkte 17 A und B Beratung
der Beschlussempfehlungen des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
zu den Anträgen der Fraktion Die Linke
mit dem titelstrom und gassperren
verbieten sowie Gas und strompreisdeckel
einführen über die Beschlussempfehlung
zu dem Antrag der Fraktion Die Linke mit
dem Titel Strom und gassperren verbieten
werden wir später namentlich abstimmen
verabredet ist es 68 Minuten zu
debattieren und ich eröffne die
Aussprache und die erste Rednerin ist
für Bündnis 90 die Grünen dr Ingrid
Nestler
jetzt also zwei Anträge der
Linksfraktion verbraucher sollen wegen
Zahlungsfähigkeit nicht mehr gesperrt
werden dürfen das ist der eine Antrag
doch zunächstle Mietpreise sie sind
bitter für viele Menschen in diesem Land
und für viele Unternehmen und ich bin
sicher dass es keinen Abgeordneten und
keine Abgeordnete in diesem Haus gibt
die das nicht wissen mir persönlich hat
das schon mehrmals nachts den Schlaf
geraubt und ich glaube wir können die
Debatte heute und hier auf das
Wesentliche konzentrieren wenn wir das
einfach erstmal festhalten wenn wir
nicht versuchen uns gegenseitig klar zu
machen wie schlimm die Situation ist und
dabei hoffen dass es so rüberkam als
hätten die anderen das nicht gemerkt wir
alle haben es gemerkt deswegen sollten
wir die Debatten Zeit heute dafür zu
nutzen darüber zu reden wie wir den
Menschen und Unternehmen am besten
helfen können
zum einen ist natürlich Unterstützung
wichtig direkte Unterstützung wir haben
mittlerweile im vierten Paket viel Geld
mobilisiert viel Kraft mobilisiert um
Menschen um Unternehmen in der Not zu
helfen um sie zu unterstützen das ist
gut so das brauchen wir
wir Grüne haben uns immer dafür
eingesetzt dass diese Gelder möglichst
zielgenau bei denjenigen ankommen
Menschen und Unternehmen die sie haben
dringendsten brauchen aber es ist auch
klar die Gelder müssen schnell und
unbürokratisch schließen und das
bedeutet eben auch dass sie nicht ganz
so zielgenau sein könnten wir wenn man
sehr sehr komplizierte prüfungssysteme
aufsetzt
wir haben also
wir haben den klaren Willen und die
Kraft bewiesen Menschen und Unternehmen
zu unterstützen das andere aber was wir
brauchen was auf der Hand liegt und was
manchmal zu kurz kommt ist wir müssen
und das ist doch die einzige Lösung die
das Problem wirklich an der Wurzel packt
wir müssen unabhängiger werden von
diesen unbezahlbaren
vorzielen wir müssen unabhängiger werden
und deshalb bin ich sehr stolz auf diese
ampelregierung die es geschafft hat das
größte erneuerbaren Energien
Ausbauprogramm aller Zeiten aufzulegen
und schon wieder nachgelegt hat und
insig in der vorletzten Sitzungswoche
deshalb freue ich mich sehr dass wir mit
Minister Habeck ein Minister haben der
wirklich handelt der sich nicht
wegdrückt wenn es schwierig wird der die
Beschleunigung von Genehmigung
hinbekommen hat wie keiner vor ihm und
auch an Energiesparverordnung auf den
Tisch gelegt hat
werden sie gerne in der Zwischenfrage
dann erzähle ich Ihnen ganz viel was
Minister haben gemacht hat aber so
möchte ich die Zeit nicht denn was wir
natürlich auch machen müssen ja wir
brauchen andere Energiequellen aber was
natürlich auch machen müssen um
unabhängiger zu werden von diesen
derzeit unbezahlbaren fossilen die
deshalb so unbezahlbar sind weil wir ein
bisschen zu viel verbrauchen es gibt ja
keinen Grund dafür dass Gas aus Norwegen
so teuer sein muss wie es derzeit ist
außer dass wir eben etwas mehr
verbrauchen als wir haben etwas mehr
verbrauchen dass wir beziehen können was
wir also auch machen müssen ist den
Verbrauch zu reduzieren und einzusparen
in der Industrie genauso wie in den
Haushalten
und da verehrt Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der Linksfraktion die sie heute wieder
die Themen auf den Tisch gelegt haben da
hat mich ihr Verhalten den letzten
Wochen schon sehr verwundert ich habe
sie mehrmals persönlich darauf
hingewiesen dass unsere einsparappelle
unser Aufruf zur Solidarität weniger zu
verbrauchen von dem knappen Gut Erdgas
dass sie sich eben nicht gerade an die
Leute richten die gerade kein Geld mehr
haben es zu bezahlen sondern an die
gesamte Gesellschaft und in erster Linie
an die reichen die am meisten Energie
verbrauchen und die sparen können
und wäre ich heute nicht die erste
Rednerin ich hätte Wetten abgeschlossen
wann der erste das Wort Waschlappen auf
dem Tisch bringt ja ein Wort das einmal
erwähnt worden ist völlig aus dem
Kontext gerissen hunderttausend Mal
100.000 mal wieder
verwendet worden ist um all diejenigen
die unsere Gesellschaft zusammenhalten
und vor großer Not bewahren wollen die
unserer Gesellschaft sagen wollen dass
wir gemeinsam diesen knappen Gut Erdgas
eben seriös und sparsam umgehen müssen
um all diese zu diskreditieren und
lächerlich zu machen ich habe sie darauf
hingewiesen sie haben es immer wieder
gemacht das ist nicht Schutz derjenigen
der Menschen mit wenig Geld genau
dadurch treiben sie das Problem in die
Höhe sie machen die in den lächerlich
die etwas für die Gesellschaft tun
wollen und die die Energiepreise nach
unten bringen für den billigen
politischen Punkt ja sie wollen den
politischen billigen Punkt in den Social
Media sie wollen viele Klicks und viele
Likes aber David herrscht verschärfen
sie das Problem damit heizen Sie das
Problem an die wenn die zehn Prozent
reichsten in Deutschland einfach nur so
viel Energie verbrauchen würden wie ein
Durchschnittsbürger dann den Kollegen
sind 20% eingespart
Frau Kollegin kommen Sie bitte zum
Schluss sie sagen
Frau Kollegin ich habe auch was gesagt
ich habe auch recht
ich muss
kaum zu stoppen von den bündnisgrün es
geht um zwei Anträge der Linken einmal
fordern sie sperren für Verbraucher
wegen einer Zahlungsunfähigkeit soll es
nicht mehr geben und zum anderen einen
energiepreisträger für Strom und Gas
soll dringend her und zwar anders
ausgestaltet als der den die Kommission
zumindest beim Gas vorgeschlagen hat
Marie lena weiß jetzt für die CDU CSU
weil der Doppel Worms offensichtlich
noch nicht so Wurst wer soll wollen Sie
jetzt mit dem Verbot von Strom und Gas
sperren dafür sorgen dass die Wohnzimmer
im Winter warm bleiben ich sage das ist
einer der schlechtesten Vorschläge die
momentan auf dem Tisch liegen und ich
will Ihnen gern darlegen warum halten
wir zunächst einmal fest wenn wir heute
über Strom und Gas sperren diskutieren
dann diskutieren wir nicht mehr über die
290.000 Anschlüsse die im Jahr 2019
gesperrt wurden oder über die 230.000
Anschlüsse im Jahr 2020 wir sprechen
über Millionen von Strom und
Gasanschlüssen von den Geringverdienern
bis weit in die Mittelschicht hinein
jeder dritte Bürger in diesem Land hat
jetzt genau in diesem Moment Angst die
Strom- und Gasrechnung nicht mehr
bezahlen zu können jeder dritte Betrieb
bankt um seine Existenz
diese dramatische Situation lässt sich
nicht durch ein Verbot von Gas und
Stromsparen in die Zukunft verschieben
sondern muss jetzt bei der Wurzel
gepackt werden
Sperrungen zu verbieten das mag ein paar
Monate gut gehen aber das kann doch
nicht die Lösung sein denn eines ist
klar an dem Tag an dem die Politik das
Verbot wieder aufhebt fällt das
Kartenhaus in sich zusammen
es steht doch außer Frage dass derjenige
der eine Leistung entgegengenommen hat
in diesem Fall Strom oder Gas bezogen
hat irgendwann für diese Leistung auch
bezahlen muss egal ob heute in einem
Monat oder in einem Jahr dieser Tag wird
zweifelsohne kommen und dann wird das
Ausmaß der Bugwelle die betroffenen
Bürger schlagartig in die Realität
zurückholen das war der eine Punkt
der andere ist wer soll ihren Vorschlag
den eigentlich bezahlen der Staat die
Allgemeinheit die Energieversorger ihr
Antrag Liebe linke schweigt dazu ich
kann das verstehen schließlich sind sie
ja fürs verteilen da und nicht das
Erwirtschaften zuständig aber klar ist
doch dass diese Kosten zunächst bei den
Energieversorgung hängen bleiben allen
voran bei unseren 900 Stadtwerken in
Deutschland den 900 Stadtwerken für die
der Wirtschaftsminister nicht zuständig
ist und an die auch Sie wie Sie mit
Ihrem Antrag zeigen nicht denken durch
ihren Vorschlag Gas und Stromsperren zu
verbieten gefährden sie die
wirtschaftliche Existenz der Versorger
und Stadtwerke die in Vorleistung gehen
ihre Lieferzusage einhalten aber keine
Gegenleistung mehr bekommen
der der Versorger die für die Energie
Grundversorgung als Teil der
Daseinsvorsorge da sind und die den
Kunden ja ohnehin schon Ratenzahlungen
von mindestens sechs Monaten anbieten
müssen sie bestrafen also die Stadtwerke
die schon immer sozialgerecht agieren
die alles dafür tun die Kunden vor Ort
zu schonen und für die Gas und
Stromsperren schon immer die absolut die
ultima ratio waren vor allem aber sorgen
sie durch ihren Vorschlag dafür dass der
Allgemeinheit auf zweifache Weise
Schaden entsteht zum einen weil die
Preise wieder steigen werden denn
Ausfälle werden durch die zahlenden
Kunden kompensiert und zum anderen weil
sie den Stadtwerken die wirtschaftliche
Grundlage entziehen damit können Sie
Ihre Gewinne nicht für die Schwimmbäder
den ÖPNV oder die Transformation zur
Klimaneutralität einsetzen
Liebe linke sehen sie ein dass uns Ihr
Antrag nicht weiterhilft und helfen Sie
stattdessen mit die Regierung davon zu
überzeugen dass die beste Entlastung und
Preisbremse nicht ein Verbot von Strom
und gassperren ist die beste Entlastung
erreichen wir durch eine Erhöhung des
energieangebots
ich sage ausdrücklich danke liebe
Regierung dass Sie den Weg frei gemacht
haben beim biogast Deckel und ich bitte
sie erhöhen Sie das Tempo bei der Kohle
legen Sie die Scheuklappen bei
heimischer Gasförderung ab zeigen sie
sich einsichtig bei der Kernenergie und
lassen Sie alle drei aktiven
Kernkraftwerke am Netz
die Intention ihres zweiten antragsliebe
Linksfraktion ist ja gut gemeint wenn
auch inhaltlich nicht umsetzbar sehen
Sie es mir deshalb an dieser Stelle nach
wenn ich mich nicht mit ihrem dürftigen
Dreizeiler auseinandersetze sondern mich
stattdessen noch einmal klar und
deutlich an sie Wände Liebe
Bundesregierung es ist
aus Vision Gas externen insbesondere
wirtschaftlichen Sachverstand ins Boot
geholt haben schade dass sie das nicht
schon vor der Sommerpause gemacht haben
als absehbar war in welcher Situation
wir uns vor dem nahenden Winter befinden
ich appelliere an Sie sorgen Sie dafür
dass unsere mittelständischen Betriebe
jetzt kurzfristig Entlastung bekommen
eine gaspreisbremse im März kommt zu
spät bei einer Verzehnfachung der Preise
am Spotmarkt können Betriebe nicht
einfach fünf Monate weiter produzieren
eine Einmalzahlung im Dezember reicht
nicht aus und drohen die
Betriebsschließungen im Winter zu
verhindern sorgen Sie dafür dass
zumindest schnelle Anpassungen am
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm und
Liquiditätshilfen für spürbare
Entlastung sorgen bis die gaspreisbremse
kommt und vor allem denken Sie daran
dass mit der gaspreisbremse erst die
Hälfte getan ist vergessen Sie nicht das
Stromproblem und kümmern Sie sich um die
Strompreise und lassen sie zu guter
Letzt auch nicht diejenigen im Regen
stehen die am Öl hängen und auf Pellets
angewiesen sind und ebenfalls hohen
Preissteigerungen ausgesetzt sind
Liebe Bundesregierung ihr Kanzler hat
gestern prophetenhaft verkündet dass er
Putins gaserpressung schon im letzten
Winter vorausgesehen habe für die
Zukunft rate ich Ihnen verkünden sie
ihre Prophezeiungen leiser und handeln
Sie stattdessen schneller und spürbarer
geben Sie unseren Bürgern und betrieben
eine Perspektive wie sie durch den
Winter kommen
[Applaus]
was die Strom- und gassperren angeht da
gibt es ja unterschiedliche Meinungen in
der Ampel Bundesjustizminister Buschmann
hatte sich skeptisch zu einem Vorstoß
von Verbraucherschutzministerin Lemke
geäußert die einen Moratorium für Strom
und Gas sperren ins Gespräch gebracht
hatte Nina Scheer jetzt für die
SPD-Sprecherin für Klimaschutz und
Energie
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist von der
Kollegin Ingrid Nestle gerade schon
dargelegt worden wir haben eine fossile
energiepreiskrise das dürfen wir bei all
dem nicht vergessen wir hätten keine
preisprobleme mit der Energie wenn wir
schon längst beschleunigt auf
erneuerbare Energien umgestiegen werden
und wir wissen dass es hier schon
vielfache diskutiert worden ich erwähne
es erneut dass da auch in der großen
Koalition leider kräftige Bremsen
installiert wurden und wir hatten alle
Mühe als SPD-Fraktion diese Bremsen
abzuwehren
wir müssen jetzt schauen dass wir
natürlich sowohl die Entlastung
hinbekommen die wir brauchen
aufgrund dieser fossilen
energiepreiskrise und diese Entlastung
sind auf dem Weg wir haben schon über 95
Milliarden an den Entlastung auf dem Weg
gebracht wir fangen also nicht
keineswegs bei Null an und jetzt sind
200 Milliarden über einen erneuten
Abwehrschirm verständigt die jetzt in
die Ausgestaltung müssen das ist eine
große Aufgabe die wir noch vor uns haben
da ist natürlich darum geht das gerecht
auszugestalten und genau da liegt ja
auch der Ansatz
dass man erst überhaupt nicht zu den
Strom- und Gas sperren kommt das ist der
wirksame Ansatz dies eben zu verhindern
denn wenn man dies nicht täte dann wäre
natürlich die Konsequenz dass ein
Unterbinden von Strom und gasperren nur
Schulden anhäufen würde und das mit gilt
es ja gerade zu verhindern deswegen ist
der erste wichtige Schritt deswegen ist
der erste wichtige Schritt dass man
natürlich diese Entlastungen auf den Weg
bringen um diese Schuldensituation bei
den Menschen nicht entstehen zu lassen
und natürlich den folgeeffekt der dann
ja auch eintrete dass die Stadtwerke die
kommunalen Stadtwerke dass die Versorger
dann das auf diesen auf diesen nicht
bezahlten Rechnungen sitzen blieben dass
die dann eben auch nicht das an als
Problem vor die Tür bekommen deswegen
ist es wichtig dass man in dieser
zweierlei in diesen zweierlei Hinsichten
diese entlastungspakete schnell auf den
Weg bringt
als andere Koalition und auch als
SPD-Fraktion machen wir natürlich da
nicht Halt denn wir wissen es kann
trotzdem hier und da zu kritischen
Situationen kommen und deswegen haben
wir uns auch dafür ausgesprochen dass es
abwendungsvereinbarungen geben soll und
dass dafür auch das Energierecht
nachgebessert werden muss wenn man das
anders nicht hinbekommt das haben wir
uns klar ausgesprochen dass eben hier
eine klare Verankerung hin muss dass
eine
abwendungsvereinbarungen
gearbeitet wird und das bedeutet
natürlich dann auch dass wir vom Ziel
her vom Ergebnis her diese Fälle
unterbinden wollen ja es soll keine
Strom- und gasperren geben aber der Weg
dahin ist eben entscheidend damit es
nicht zu diesen von mir gerade schon
genannten Überforderungen kommt
ich möchte aber zu dem erstgenannten
Punkt noch mal zurückkommen denn es sagt
sich immer so leicht dass wir hier
mitten in einer
Preiskrise sind und dass wir schnell
umsteigen und ich möchte einmal kurz
sehr werden weil es tags aktuell
unverzichtbar ist darauf zu Rückzug zu
bekommen oder das zu erwähnen auch an
dieser Stelle auf europäischer Ebene
ist gerade ein sehr großer Kampf darum
welche Rolle die erneuerbaren Energien
wie schnell haben werden und es muss für
uns alle klar sein dass wir von diesem
Pfad der das beschleunigten Umstiegs auf
erneuerbare auch aus Preisgründen aus
bezahlbarkeitsgründen nicht abweichen
dass wir so beschleunigt wie nur irgend
geht auf erneuerbare umsteigen der
eu-wirtschaftsausschuss hat heute daran
ein Fragezeichen gesetzt und auch einige
EU-Staaten wollen das im Repower
EU-Programm nun auch das 45% erneuerbare
Ziel bis 2030 aufgeweicht wird von
unserer Seite muss ganz klar sein das
ist nicht die Antwort die Antwort lautet
erneuerbare so schnell wie möglich das
sind die kostengünstigsten Formen der
Energiegewinnung und wenn wir von diesem
Pfad abweichen dann wird auch kein
Rettungspaket der Welt mehr
Bezahlbarkeit von Energie-
Möglichkeit der Energieversorgung heißt
energiewendebeschleunigung vielen Dank
jetzt spricht Marc Bernhard für die
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
also nach dem was ich jetzt gerade hier
schon in dieser Debatte alles gehört
habe wo sich doch schon sagen die
Regierung hat ganz offensichtlich die
Dramatik nicht verstanden bei Frau
Nestle sie haben ja sinngemäß im Prinzip
gesagt wenn die Menschen sich die
Energie nicht mehr leisten können dann
sollen sie halt in Zukunft weniger
verbrauchen das haben sie im Prinzip
gesagt und ich glaube ich muss schon
einmal daran erinnern dass die
Spritpreise seit Jahresbeginn um 60
Prozent gestiegen sind sich die
Strompreise verdoppelt haben und der
graspreis sich mehr als verdreifacht hat
wenn also eine vierköpfige Familie an
Anfang des Jahres 1200 Euro fürs Gas
bezahlt hat da muss sie heute 4000 Euro
bezahlen und über die Preisexplosion bei
den Lebensmitteln haben wir noch gar
darüber gesprochen aber sprechen wir ich
nein ich bitte dann um eine
zwischenintervention nachher aber
sprechen wir doch mal darüber warum denn
die Menschen überhaupt in dieser
Notsituation sind ja lassen Sie mich
doch erstmal meinen Gedanken entwickeln
dann können sie nachher gerne eine
Intervention machen sprechen wir doch
erstmal darüber warum denn die Menschen
überhaupt in dieser Notsituation sind
nämlich ganz einfach weil die Regierung
acht Monate lang nichts gemacht hat und
diese Katastrophe abzuwenden laut
Minister Habeck zählt doch angeblich
jede Kilowattstunde bereits am 6 April
habe ich den Bundeskanzler gefragt was
die Regierung unternommen hat um die
Laufzeitverlängerung und die wieder in
Betriebnahme der Kernkraftwerke zeitnah
zu erreichen um damit für bezahlbare
Energie zu sorgen die lapidare Antwort
von Olaf Scholz war dass die
Kernkraftwerke nicht weiterlaufen werden
am 7 Juli haben sie alle hier ausnah
eine Kurs im übrigen auch Sie von der
Union den afd-antrag die Kernkraftwerke
weiterlaufen zu lassen in einer
namentlichen Abstimmung abgelehnt seit
Monaten fordern wir Nord nordstream 2 im
Betrieb zu nehmen so haben sie jetzt so
lange gewartet bis Staatsterroristen die
Pipeline gesprengt haben aber eine
Leitung ist noch funktionsfähig und
könnte sofort den Betrieb genommen
werden
zudem fordern wir seit Monaten die
Nutzung unserer eigenen Gasvorkommen die
für die nächsten 40 Jahre russisches Gas
komplett ersetzen können
außerdem die Energiesteuer zu senken die
CO2-Steuer abzuschaffen und die
Mehrwertsteuer für Energie auf Null zu
setzen aber das haben sie ja alles
abgelehnt und haben dann angefangen uns
Märchen von lndit
lng-industrieanlagen und
wasserstoffpipelines aus Afrika zu
erzählen die uns durch diesen und den
nächsten Winter bringen sollen haben sie
die Geschichten gerade eben fortgesetzt
und wie sollen jetzt diese
Märchengeschichten denn ganz konkret
jetzt dafür sorgen dass die Menschen
über den Winter kommen nachdem sie nun
acht Monate verschlafen haben fangen Sie
jetzt an
am Anfang der Heizperiode darüber
nachzudenken was man tun könnte um den
Menschen nach dem Winter vielleicht
möglicherweise helfen zu können
also dann also genau dann wenn viele
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen bereits
pleite sind und tausende von
Arbeitsplätzen vernichtet wurden nachdem
diese Regierung also total versagt hat
muss jetzt jede Möglichkeit genutzt
werden um die Menschen und die
Unternehmen über den Winter zu bringen
und deshalb fordern auch wir eine Gas-
und strompreisdeckel jedoch nur als
akute zeitlich begrenzte Notbrücke um
Gas und Strom wieder bezahlbar zu machen
die Menschen und die Unternehmen
brauchen nämlich keine
Märchengeschichten sondern jetzt hier
und sofort massive Entlastungen denn
über den Winter kommt niemand mit einem
Bums doppelwumms unterhaken und
sonstigen inhaltslehren
Durchhalteparolen
die Energieversorger übrigens wollen auf
sperren nicht verzichten beim
Energieversorger mit Gas haben dieses
Jahr bislang etwa 17.000 Gaskunden eine
Mahnung aufgrund von Zahlungsverzug
erhalten im vergangenen Jahr waren es
insgesamt nur 13.000 900 nur in
Anführungsstrichen Michaels für die FDP
aber Weise kann man hier immer alles das
was der Rest des Hauses über ihre Reden
denkt unmittelbar formulieren das
entspannt einen persönlich sehr und gibt
einem eine große innere Freiheit
tatsächlich entfernt es einen aber ein
bisschen davon das zu sagen was wir
alles Gutes machen und ich habe mich für
heute mal entschlossen genau darauf
einzugehen denn nicht mal die fünf
Minuten werden dafür reichen ihnen zu
erklären was wir alles schon unternommen
haben und in den nächsten Wochen und
Monaten doch Unternehmen werden um
dieses Land aus der Abhängigkeit zu
bringen die wir in Energiebereich von
Russland haben und es gibt ja noch eine
große Gemeinsamkeit die eben die Mitte
Fraktionen dieses Hauses vereint nämlich
das wir aus der großen Abhängigkeit von
einem Staat der Energie als Waffe gegen
uns in Westeuropa einsetzt rausführen
wollen das wollen sie am rechten Rand ja
gar nicht sie wollen uns weiter in
dieser Abhängigkeit reinführen und der
Anschluss von Nord Stream 2 wie sie ihn
gerade gefordert haben ist der beste
Beleg dafür sie
die Augen zu vor einem brutalen
Angriffskrieg und wollen noch größere
Abhängigkeiten von Russland und die
Tatsache dass sie jetzt hier so
rumschreien zeigt ich habe recht
und das ist eben der Unterschied zu der
sehr verantwortungsvollen Mehrheit hier
im Hause sei sie gerade in der Regierung
oder auch in der Opposition wir sorgen
für Energieunabhängigkeit von Russland
wir sorgen dafür dass wir unsere eigenen
Geschicke wieder in die eigenen Hände
nehmen können und ja mittelfristig ist
der Ausbau der Erneuerbaren der
freiheitsenergien der beste Weg um genau
das zu erreichen und jeder hätte das
eigentlich erkennen müssen jeder könnte
das erkennen dass das jetzt der richtige
Weg ist nun gab es ja auch noch den
Anwurf damit kommen wir nicht durch den
nächsten Winter nee stimmt deswegen
haben gerade die energiepolitikerinnen
und Politiker die hier ja im Raum
vertreten sind bis hierhin mehr Gesetze
verhandelt als das glaube ich jemals in
diesem Bereich in dieser Geschwindigkeit
stattgefunden hat und nein
es bringt uns nicht durch den nächsten
Winter dass wir in zwei bis fünf Jahren
noch ganz andere zubauziele in bei den
Erneuerbaren erreicht haben wollen aber
es bringt uns durch den Winter das stand
heute 95 Prozent Füllstand in den
deutschen gasspeichern vorhanden ist
etwas was die Russen im letzten Jahr
verhindert haben weil sie ein Gutteil
davon besessen haben das ist etwas wofür
wir gesorgt haben weil wir im März
dieses Jahres Gesetze gemacht haben die
uns durch den nächsten Winter bringt da
waren sie wie üblich nur mit pöbeln
beschäftigt sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren von der rechten und wir verändern
unsere importquellen und das in
Rekordgeschwindigkeit ja warum haben wir
denn neuerdings LNG Import Terminals
warum sind wir denn in den fsa-news dran
warum haben wir denn Infrastrukturausbau
in diesem Land in einer Geschwindigkeit
wie es ihnen die letzten Jahrzehnte
nicht gegeben hat weil die Ampel dafür
gesorgt hat weil wir verantwortungsvoll
für dieses Land handeln und weil wir den
Menschen eine klar Perspektive dafür
geben wie wir durch die nächsten beiden
Winter kommen damit dieses Land nicht in
die größte Rezession seiner Geschichte
Gerät sondern damit dieses Land
Zuversicht erhält und denn dieser
Zuversicht an der kann jeder hier im
Haus mitarbeiten und ehrlich gesagt ich
erwarte es auch von jedem in diesem Haus
dass er daran mitarbeitet denn die
Menschen in diesem Land die
interessieren sich überhaupt nicht dafür
ob nun diese Partei oder jene Partei
gerade mal was vorgeschlagen hat die
interessieren sich dafür dass wir Ihre
Probleme lösen und dass wir dafür sorgen
dass genügend Energie in den nächsten
Monaten und vor allem in den nächsten
beiden Wintern zur Verfügung steht und
ein Thema ist da eine ganze Menge haben
wir gemacht wir bringen wieder
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz obwohl es
keiner gewollt hat in der Koalition vor
dem Angriffskrieg wir sehen was
notwendig ist ein Thema das im Moment
noch in der Diskussion ist ist wie viel
wir bei der Kernenergie tun sie wissen
wir als Freie Demokraten sprechen uns
dafür aus dass wir hier mehr Kapazitäten
ans Netz nehmen ich habe in der Zeitung
gelesen es gäbe einen Streit darüber ich
kann nur davor warnen kann nur davor
warnen jede inhaltliche Diskussion die
mit unterschiedlichen Zielen aber in der
Sache vernünftig geführt wird als ein
solchen Streit zu deklarieren
wir Freie Demokraten
wir Freie Demokraten werben dafür dass
wir mehr Kapazität ans Netz bringen als
das aktuellste Szenario im Stresstest
beschreibt warum weil sich der
Stresstest in den letzten Wochen bereits
überholt hat und wir wollen nicht in
eine Lage kommen in der wir sagen müssen
es ist noch schlechter gekommen als wir
uns das haben vorstellen können wir
würden lieber in einer Lage sein in der
wir hinterher sagen können wir hätten es
nicht unbedingt machen müssen aber das
werden wir erst hinterher erfahren wir
sorgen mit Sicherheit Planbarkeit und
Verlässlichkeit dafür dass die Menschen
in diesem Land Hoffnung und Zuversicht
bekommen können meine Damen und Herren
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Michael Kruse von der FDP voller
Hoffnung und Zuversicht anders sieht das
sicherlich Amira Moa mit Ali die
Fraktionsvorsitzende der Linken der
Bundestag debattiert über zwei Entwürfe
der Linken einmal fordern sie die
Sperren für Verbraucher wegen einer
Zahlungsunfähigkeit nicht mehr
zu verhängen und zum anderen ein
energiepreisdeckel für Strom und Gas der
aber anders gestaltet ist als der der
Kommission
muss sie aufbrauchen wer keine hat kommt
in größte Schwierigkeiten die Schlangen
bei den Tafeln werden immer länger immer
mehr Menschen sind betroffen die niemals
erwartet hätten in so eine Lage zu
kommen immer mehr Menschen sind
überschuldet die Zahl der
Unternehmensinsolvenzen ist im Vergleich
zum Vorjahr um 34 Prozent gestiegen in
dieser großen Krise braucht es endlich
klare und entschlossene Maßnahmen es
muss Schluss sein mit dem teuerwahnsinn
Deckeln sie Strom und Gaspreise jetzt
Kolleginnen und Kollegen außerdem ist es
zwingend notwendig die allergrößten
sozialen Härten nicht nur ein kleines
bisschen abzumildern sie müssen
ausgeschlossen werden darum muss es
sofort verboten werden dass Menschen die
in Zahlungsschwierigkeiten sind das den
Strom oder Gas in ihrer Wohnung
abgeschaltet werden darf Schluss mit
Strom und gassperren und keiner
behauptet dass das die alleinige Lösung
ist natürlich nicht aber es ist eben ein
wichtiger Baustein was macht die
Bundesregierung sie will eine Gaspreis
Verbraucher und für Handwerksbetriebe ab
März das ist das denn eine Preisbremse
am Ende der Heizperiode wirklich damit
die Preise über den Winter noch
ungestört die Rechnung ist unermessliche
weiter steigen können Sie schauen
einfach zu wie immer größere Teil der
Bevölkerung für Armen Sie schauen
einfach zu das Handwerksbetriebe
reihenweise werden aufgeben müssen das
ist die Wahrheit aber das geht so nicht
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und dann wollen sie den Preis Deckeln
und zwar bei 12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde
das ist das Doppelte das
vorjahrespreises für viele ist das immer
noch viel zu viel welche Antwort haben
sie für all diese Menschen ach ja sie
übernehmen die Abschlagszahlungen für
Gaskunden für einen Monat hat
Donnerwetter ich meine sie müssen doch
selber merken dass diese spärliche
Einmalzahlung hinten und vorne nicht
ausreicht in anderen Ländern gibt es
längst einen preisdeckel in Frankreich
zum Beispiel seit Oktober 2021 lange vor
Putins Krieg so viel dazu dass es
angeblich nicht möglich sein soll die
Preise auf Vorkriegsniveau zu bringen
herr Herbert doch das geht und genau das
brauchen wir auch hier
ihre Preisbremse ist zu spät und zu
schlecht und wo ist eigentlich der
preisdeckel für Heizöl wo ist der
preisdeckel für Strom haben sie doch
angekündigt wo ist er denn wissen sie
bevor ich im Bundestag gekommen bin war
ich zehn Jahre lang als Juristin in der
freien Wirtschaft angestellt und ich
kann Ihnen sagen für so schlechte Arbeit
wird man überall sonst entlassen und
zwar zu Recht vor der Landtagswahl in
Niedersachsen noch große Töne spucken
und
einen Tag dieser Luftnummer um die Ecke
von wegen doppelbums ihr doppelbums ist
eine rohrkrippierer das grenzt an
Wählertäuschung das ist die Wahrheit und
auch das geht so nicht und dass sie
immer noch nicht verstanden haben wie
ernst die Lage das hat man auch in den
Regen hier vorgehört das merkt man eben
daran dass sie es immer noch zulassen
das Verbrauchern zu Hause den
finanziellen Schwierigkeiten sind das
dem Strom und Gas in der Wohnung
abgeschaltet werden darf sie kennen die
Zahlen bisher wo traf das eine Million
Menschen oder eine Haushalte beim Strom
pro Jahr 270.000 beim Gas in diesem Jahr
so melden viele Stadtwerke wird die
Zahlungsausfällen von bis zu 15 Prozent
gerechnet 15 Prozent Millionen Haushalte
werden betroffen sein eine Millionen
Wohnungen droht es bald sehr kalt und
sehr dunkel zu werden wenn sie nicht
jetzt handeln es gibt nur einen Weg
stimmen Sie unserem Antrag zu verbieten
sie Strom und Gas sperren
und natürlich braucht es parallel dazu
einen Schutz schon für die Stadtwerke
ist doch keine Frage habe ich was hält
sie davon ab spannen Sie diesen
Schutzschirm doch endlich auf ja wir
brauchen diese Sofortmaßnahmen um die
Härten abzumildern die jetzt bestehen
aber das nämlich das zum Schluss sagen
es müssen auch die richtigen Lehren aus
dieser Krise gezogen werden die
Energieversorgung darf nicht länger den
Kräften des freien Marktes ausgeliefert
bleiben wir sehen doch wo das hinführt
Energieversorgung ist Daseinsvorsorge
sie gehört in öffentliche Hand danke
schön
Amira [ __ ] mit Ali hat hier noch einmal
begründet warum die Linksfraktion diese
beiden Anträge stellt allerdings sind
sie im Ausschuss schon abgelehnt worden
nachher wird namentlich abgestimmt über
den ersten Antrag sperren für
Verbraucher wegen einer
Zahlungsunfähigkeit nicht mehr
zuzulassen dann hat Hermann jetzt für
die Bundesregierung als Gesellschaft
mehr noch als sonst zum starken
Zusammenhalt und auch wir hier im Haus
sind dabei ein besonderer Verantwortung
hohe Energiepreise sind eine gewaltige
Herausforderung Unternehmen sehen sich
existenziell bedroht bürger:innen wissen
oft nicht wie sie die hohen Zahlungen
stemmen sollen und wenn wir da nicht
gegensteuern würden dann drohte darüber
auch der gesellschaftliche Zusammenhalt
in Europa zu zerbrechen genau das aber
will Putin und ich habe den Eindruck
auch manche hier im Haus
bereits vor dem russischen Angriff auf
die Ukraine begann die Verknappung
russischen gases
der Angriff auf unsere Energieversorgung
begann dann nämlich bereits schon die
externe gasmangelage ist die Ursache für
hohe Preise und ja Frau weiß sie gerade
gucken gerade weg Frau weiß es war
erkennen beim letzten Winter ich war
nämlich bei Stadtwerken schon gewesen
die im letzten Winter schon das
Beklagten auch wenn Frau Merkel sagte
alles in Ordnung Putin liefert
ordentlich die Gasspeicher waren mehr
man konnte und musste es sehen und
frühzeitig handeln
aber wir werden uns da Herausforderung
als Gesellschaft geschlossen stellen wir
werden die Spaltung nicht zulassen aber
nochmal wir die wir Verantwortung tragen
in Bund Ländern und Kommunen haben
gemeinsam die Herausforderung
konstruktiv anzupacken dabei ist
entschlossen das schnelles aber auch
kluges abgewogenes Handeln gefragt die
ampelkollektion tut ihren Teil um
schnell und zugleich wirksam zu helfen
und Lösung zu Preissenkung
voranzubringen mit der Strom- und
gaspressbremse schützt der
bundbürgerinnen und Unternehmen vor den
hohen Energiepreisen das vor allem ist
Grundlage dass es gar nicht erst zur
Außenstände und energiesperren kommen
muss und die Bundesregierung hat auch
beschlossen den Schutz vor Strom und Gas
Sperren zu erhöhen
aber nicht simple einfache Lösung ein
Instrument und alles ist gut das wird
nicht funktionieren insgesamt brauchen
wir die Perspektive direkt Betroffener
von verschiedenen Akteuren hier ist
mehrfach angesprochen worden an der
scharnierstelle zwischen BürgerInnen
Wirtschaft und Kommunen stehen in aller
Regel und das gerade auch in
Ostdeutschland regionale kommunale
Energieunternehmen der Austausch mit
ihnen war und ist mir insbesondere
wichtig auch deren Belange fließenden
unseren Entscheidungen direkt ein und
ich bin froh dass die
ministerpräsident:innen letzte Woche mit
dem Bundeskanzler ihre besondere
Bedeutung betont und festgehalten haben
dass insbesondere Stadtwerken bei Bedarf
zusätzliche Unterstützung zukommen soll
über die energiepreisbremsen hinaus
das ist richtig denn die Unterstützung
wird der besonderen vernetzenden und
damit stabilisierenden Rolle dieser
zumeist öffentlichen Akteure gerecht
letzten Endes das gehört unbedingt zur
Wahrheit sind und bleiben die
Möglichkeiten für finanzielle Entlastung
durch den Bund und auch die Länder
begrenzt darum müssen alle Haushalte
gewerbehandel Industrie überall
womöglich sich mit der Energie
nachhaltiger aufstellen klugenergie
einsparen gehört dazu effizient Energie
nutzen und eigene Potenziale zu
Erzeugung mit Solarenergie auch mit dem
bürgerwindrat mit dem Unternehmen Rat zu
nutzen immer mehr tun das auch und das
ist gut so dass das Gehen Vertretern der
Konzernen Energiekonzerne nicht gefällt
ist mir schon klar die Zukunft gehört in
Erneuerbaren wir sehen schon heute wie
stark diese bei uns den Strompreis
senken haben wir viel erneuerbare
Energien aus Sonne und Wind im Netz
liegt der Großhandelspreise in
Deutschland schon jetzt immer öfter
deutlich unter den Preisen unser
Nachbarn ja wir haben viel angeschoben
wie investle gesagt hat
und das Schöne ist nämlich und das
gefällt Konzernvertreter natürlich nicht
das schöne an sonn- und Windenergie ist
doch dass sie alle und fast überall
nutzen können so alle an der
Energiewende auch teilhaben können
kurz gesagt wenn wir das Angebot erhöhen
mit immer mehr erneuerbaren und
gleichzeitig den Verbrauch senken
bekommen wir die Energiepreise wieder in
den Griff bis dahin müssen wir
diejenigen unter uns entlasten die es
wirklich dringend brauchen so sieht
Solidarität aus ja und bei geringerer
Nachfrage sinken auch die Preise gerade
für die die es wirklich
dringend nötig haben und die nicht
selber mehr sparen können und deswegen
ist deshalb der Appell so wichtig
deswegen sind die Aufrufe zum Einsparen
so immens wichtig wenn wir als
Gesellschaft zusammenhalten werden wir
unsere weist sich echte Nachhaltigkeit
die Energiekrise meistern und
langfristig sogar gestärkt daraus
hervorgehen vielen Dank
an den König hat jetzt das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen genau vor einem
Jahr auf den Tag genau veröffentlichte
die Europäische Kommission einen
Werkzeugkasten für die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten das Ziel schnell
Maßnahmen für die steigenden
Energiepreise zu ergreifen die
Kommission schlug zum Beispiel vor den
Steuersatz auf Strom Gas Kohle und feste
Brennstoffe zu ermäßigen und gezielte
Maßnahmen zur Unterstützung für
energieintensive Betriebe zu ergreifen
der Bedarf für solche
Unterstützungsmaßnahmen war ja bereits
vor einem Jahr für jeden zu erkennen der
russische Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
hat die Probleme dann noch mal drastisch
weiter verschärft und wir können also
festhalten bereits beim
Regierungsantritt Lagen der Ampel also
solide Bausteine für ein
Unterstützungsprogramm vor ganz frei
Haus und ohne Einsetzung einer
aufwendigen Expertenkommission und was
und was hat sie damit gemacht
ganz lange erstmal gar nichts die Frage
lautet doch warum hat diese Regierung so
viel Zeit gebraucht um Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen die Menschen erkennen hier
aber inzwischen schon ein System zögern
Zaudern abwarten sind längst zur
Arbeitsmethode dieser Regierung geworden
und das setzt sich bei ihrem doppelwumms
fort es spricht ja schon für sich wenn
der Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland seine Politik nur noch in
der comicsprache ausdrücken kann aber
nicht nur Ihre Sprache nicht nur ihre
Sprache sondern auch ihre Inhalte haben
etwas unseriöses denn treffender müsste
man nicht von Doppel Wumms sondern von
doppel-wirversprechen erstens wann und
wie genau soll denn nun die
gaspreisbremse kommen trotz großer
Ankündigung ist immer noch völlig unklar
welche Handlungsempfehlung der
Expertenkommission die Ampel überhaupt
am Ende umsetzen wird und zweitens weder
der Bund noch die Länder wissen wie all
das finanziert werden soll es gibt weder
eine Einigung bei dem dritten
Entlastungspaket noch bei den
versprochenen 200 Milliarden statt
Antworten stehen bei ihnen immer mehr
Fragen im Raum
unser Popo langes Warten die
Bundesnetzagentur hat bereits im Juni
die Alarmstufe des Notfallplans Gas
ausgerufen als Reaktion darauf hat sich
die Ampel dann für zwei Monate in die
Sommerpause verabschiedet offenbar
hielten sie die Krise nicht für ernst
genug um eine Sondersitzung des
Bundestages einzuberufen wir hätten im
Sommer bereits wichtige Weichen für den
kommenden Winter stellen können wie
beispielsweise die rechtzeitige
Einführung einer gaspreisbremse dann
würde diese jetzt schon greifen
die ampelregierung scheint scheint sich
über Monate hinweg in einer Parallelwelt
aufgehalten zu haben die jedenfalls
nichts mit der Lebenswirklichkeit der
Menschen in unserem Land zu tun hat ihre
Antwort
ihre Antwort aufs steigende Gaspreise
war monatelang eine zusätzliche Umlage
die das Gas noch teurer machen sollte
und ihre Antwort auf eine gasknappheit
bei der Wärmeerzeugung ist nach wie vor
ab Januar noch mehr Gas zu verstrom um
damit drei Kernkraftwerke zu ersetzen
mit Vernunft und Planungssicherheit hat
das alles längst nichts mehr zu tun sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren ich sage es
Ihnen ganz ehrlich dass wir bei der
ampelregierung in der schwersten Krise
unserer Nachkriegsgeschichte das haben
die Menschen in diesem Land nicht
verdient im Interesse
im Interesse von Verbrauchern und
Unternehmen müssen wir jetzt die
Preissteigerungen Bremsen aus unserer
Sicht geht das nur mit einer Erweiterung
der energieangebotsseite gleichzeitig
wollen wir für wirksam Entlastung sorgen
und trotzdem auch Sparanreize erhalten
wir wollen einen gaspreisdeckel setzen
der die Grundversorgung mit Gas wieder
bezahlbar macht um gleichzeitig
Energieeinsparungen weiter anzureizen
soll dieser auf einen Grundbedarf pro
Haushalt und Person festgelegt werden im
Übrigen findet sich dieser Vorschlag
auch in dem Werkzeugkasten der
EU-Kommission wir erinnern uns der der
Ampel seit einem Jahr vorliegt der
gaspreisdeckel muss jetzt kommen und
nicht das in sechs Monaten wenn die
Heizperiode langsam endet viele Menschen
werden einfach gar nicht so lange
durchhalten können bis diese Regierung
versucht zu Ostern endlich den
Weihnachtsmann zu spielen ihre Politik
baut letztlich vor allem auf dem Prinzip
Hoffnung auf ihre Pflicht wäre es seit
Monaten gewesen zumindest eine
verlässliche faktengrundlage für ihre
Politik zu schaffen und transparent zu
machen
genau das ist auch ihre Pflicht
gegenüber dem Parlament und das fängt
auch schon bei der zentralen Frage an
wie viel Gas uns denn überhaupt zur
Verfügung steht zwar haben wir in den
letzten Wochen aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium ständig
selbstbejubelungen über die Befüllung
der Gasspeicher gehört aber tatsächlich
können sie doch nicht einmal annähernd
angeben wie viel Gas im Winter vorhanden
sein wird denn selbst das in Deutschland
eingespeicherte Gas steht ja in Wahrheit
gar nicht exklusiv für den Verbrauch in
unserem Land zur Verfügung aber ein paar
Sätze möchte ich auch zum Antrag der
Linken sagen der Vorschlag der Union für
den gaspreisdeckel ist das Gegenteil der
von der Linksfraktion vorgeschlagenen
Flatrate ihre Lösung verzichtet auf
jegliche Sparanreize und würde dafür
sorgen dass auch Gas zum Fenster raus
verheizt wird unbestritten ist dass auf
die Mieter hoheitskostenzahlungen
zukommen werden im Gegensatz zu den
linken fordern wir daher eine befristete
Aussetzung der Strom- und gassperren für
den Winter ein generelles Verbot wie
sich das die Linken ausgedacht haben
würde hingegen zu neuen
Ungerechtigkeiten führen als Fazit als
Fazit können wir festhalten es ist gut
dass auch die ampelmehrheit sich
inzwischen Richtung gasbremse bewegt
aber bitte handeln Sie auch hier dieses
Mal zügiger und vor allen Dingen
unbürokratischer vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
der Kollege Helmut hebann spricht jetzt
für die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen fast alle
Debatten des heutigen Tages stehen
natürlich unter dem Fokus der steigenden
Preise insbesondere der Energiepreise
das ist nicht erstaunlich und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger haben es verdient
dass wir uns mit der geboten
Ernsthaftigkeit auseinandersetzen und so
auch mit diesen beiden Anträgen ich will
aber zuvor zwei Vorbemerkungen machen
die eine geht an Bernhard von der AFD
ich hoffe er hat ein Kruse sehr gut
zugehört der da zwar gesagt er reagiert
nicht drauf hat aber dann dankenswert
teilweise doch darauf reagiert indem er
die lange Latte der Maßnahmen aufgezählt
hat ich komme gleich auch noch mal drauf
zurück aber wir haben in diesen acht
Monaten hart gearbeitet das Ministerium
die Ministerien haben hart gearbeitet
die Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
haben hart gearbeitet und wir haben drei
Pakete auf den Weg gemacht mit 95
Millionen das ist eine riesen Nummer
Radar Bernhard
zweite Vorbemerkung die steigenden
Preise sorgen natürlich für
Verunsicherung auch davon war immer
wieder die Rede insbesondere auch bei
der Debatte um das Bürgergeld und ich
glaube wir haben alle die Verpflichtung
für möglichst viel Sicherheit zu sorgen
der Gesellschaft den Menschen den
Familien den Unternehmen Sicherheit zu
geben und in dem Zusammenhang kann ich
es überhaupt nicht verstehen wie auf
ihrer Seite auf der rechten Seite bei
AFD und auch bei der Union ein solcher
Widerstand gegen das Zurückdrängen von
Sanktionen beim Bürgergeld entstehen
kann das ist ein Stück Sicherheit die
wir den Menschen geben indem wir in die
Angst vor Sanktionen nehmen wollen diese
Sicherheit brauchen wir meine Damen und
Herren
wir lassen die Menschen in der Krise
nicht allein das ist ja auch der
Grundgedanke bei den beiden Anträgen der
Linken das ist ja zu erkennen aus
unserer Sicht haben Sie mindestens mal
drei Schwächen mit an Bord und die will
ich kurz aufführen das erste ist schon
ein bisschen erwähnt worden es ist
keinerlei Prävention das heißt es geht
darum zu erreichen dass die Menschen gar
nicht erst in eine Situation kommen wo
ihnen möglicherweise Strom und Gas
sperren drohen wir müssen sie finanziell
so in die Lage versetzen dass das
möglich ist und genau das machen wir das
heißt unser Ansatz ist die Prävention
und nicht das nachbessern
zweiter Punkt
natürlich braucht es auch die Aktivität
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger wir werden
und das haben wir auch mehrfach hier
gehört gar nicht in der Lage sein alle
Anforderungen abzufedern wir dürfen das
Signal nicht vermitteln alles geht
weiter wie bisher es braucht die
Eigenaktivität der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und sie suggerieren mit ihren
beiden Anträgen macht so weiter wir
Deckeln das ab wir machen die Bremse
dann ist alles schick und mehr müssen
wir nicht tun das ist das falsche Signal
weil dritter Punkt wir brauchen
natürlich unbedingt die
einsparbemühungen und die brauchen wir
überall meine Damen und Herren wir
brauchen sie in der Industrie wir
brauchen sie in den Haushalten wir
brauchen sie in den Familien wir
brauchen sie im Handel beim Gewerbe wir
brauchen sie schlichtweg überall wo es
sozialverträglich möglich ist und dieses
Signal fehlt bei ihren Anträgen ganz
eindeutig deswegen ist unser Ansatz der
Ansatz der Ampel ist der richtige
gezielt zu helfen ich verweise auf das
Thema wohngeldreform haben wir gerade
diskutierter was auch immer wieder Thema
das kommt zum Heizkostenzuschuss 1 dazu
es ist sozusagen der Heizkostenzuschuss
2 das wurde hier auch schon erläutert
aus meiner Sicht genau der richtige
Schritt und vor allen Dingen wie
erweitern den Kreis der
Bezugsberechtigten das ist eine wichtige
Botschaft ins Land Welt immer Wohngeld
von Wohngeld die Rede ist sagen wir
natürlich auch die Menschen ich habe
wohl Wohngeld beantragt kriegs aber
leider nicht ich sage das wird sich ab
dem 1.1 kommenden Jahres ändern viel
mehr Menschen werden wohngeldberechtigt
sein lassen Sie uns Mut machen diese
Mittel auch zu beantragen es ist kein
Almosen es ist das gute Recht und das
hilft bei der Energiefrage
zusätzlich noch der Abwehrschirm
es ist unstreitig dass wir mit den Gas
und den Strompreisen umgehen umgehen
müssen und deswegen ist beides innerhalb
des abwehrschirms auch verabredet aber
auch hier kommt es auf die Details an
die Vorschläge der Expertenkommission
sind meines Erachtens komplett
zielführend weil sie nämlich verbinden
den einsparanreiz mit der Sicherheit für
die Haushalte in einem erträglichen Maß
über den Winter zu kommen die Dinge
bezahlbar zu halten und da ist es klar
aus meiner Sicht ist es klar dass wir
nicht auf das Preisniveau von vor der
Krise zurückkommen können nicht auf das
Preisniveau bevor Putin den Gashahn
abgedreht hat denn das ist ja letztlich
der Grund und von daher sind die Ansätze
vollkommen richtig und sie ersetzen das
was sie mit ihrem Ansatz hier Liebe
Linkspartei machen wollen wir sind auf
dem richtigen Weg
letzte Bekräftigung und letzter Satz die
Erneuerbaren sind die Lösung für
preiswerte bezahlbare und sichere
Energien zusammen mit
Speicherkapazitäten und genau das werden
wir tun dankeschön
von der SPD hat das ganze noch mal
erklärt sozusagen ist übrigens der
Vorsitzende im parlamentarischen Beirat
für nachhaltige Entwicklung der nächste
Redner kommt von der AFD Karsten Hilse
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
liebe Landsleute wie immer wenn
Kommunisten ein von ihnen
mitgeschaffenes Problem auf keinen Fall
lösen sondern nur seine Ursachen
verschleiern wollen dann verlangen sie
seine unmittelbaren Folgen zu verbieten
das kostet Sie nichts aber Sie können
sich als eine Art Robin Hood aufspielen
den Reichen nehmen und den Armen geben
das Betreiben sie dann so lange
jedenfalls wenn man sie lässt bis die
Substanz aufgebraucht oder der Kredit
verzockt ist so war es bei den auf
mikroni wo gehaltenen Miete DDR die
nicht mal die nackten
Instandhaltungskosten deckten und so ist
es jetzt wieder wenn sie verlangen Strom
und gasperren zu verbieten immer und
darauf ist Verlass wie auf das Amen in
der Kirche verlangen sie selbst mit
verschuldete Probleme zu Lasten Dritter
zu lösen besonders dann wenn es gegen
die verhassten Vermieter und andere
Kapitalisten geht dann besonders eifrig
auch wir wollen billige Strom- und
Gaspreise die jeder sich leisten aber
wenn der Dieb schreit haltet den Dieb so
wie sie jetzt dann ist es höchste Zeit
mal wieder ein Blick in die jüngste
Vergangenheit zu werfen angesponnen
angesprochen von den Grünen
kommunistischen Ideologie haben
insbesondere sie die Rechtsnachfolger
der kommunistischen SED immer wieder
nicht nur gefordert sondern auch immer
begeistert zugestimmt wenn es darum ging
das Energieangebot drastisch zu
verknappen und zu verteuern
Subventionierung der sogenannten
Erneuerbaren deutscher Alleingang beim
Atomausstieg die wohlstandsv
vernichtenden Pariser klimabeschlüsse
die unter anderem zum Kohleausstieg
führten all diese von ihnen bejubelten
Entscheidungen führten zwangsläufig zu
der jetzigen Preisexplosion sie sind
also sie sind also schuldig im Sinne der
Anklage die sie hier Vorbringen sie sind
schuldig mit all Ihnen hier die die
dümmste Energiepolitik der Welt
ausgeheckt oder mitgetragen haben und
nun wollen sie nicht etwa die Ursachen
der Preisexplosion bekämpfen nein sie
wollen wie immer nur deren Konsequenzen
jemand anderem Behörden jeder normal
denkt eine Mensch zu denen sie leider
nicht gehören weiß allein die bewusst
betriebene und von langer Hand geplante
und jetzt eingetretene
Energieverknappung ist das Problem wenn
sie nicht mit allen hier schon länger
herumsitzen diese irrwitzige realitäts-
und Fakten Ferne
industriezerstörungspolitik Betrieben
hätten bräuchte es jetzt weder gasdeckel
noch die das Verbot von Sperren
stattdessen müssen wir das Angebot
schnellstens erhöhen durch Verlängerung
der Laufzeit der Kernkraftwerke wieder
in Betriebnahme der bereits
stillgelegten durch Förderung der
riesigen schiefergeist vorkommen unseres
Landes der Reaktivierung der
Braunkohlekraftwerke sowie Öffnung der
noch intakten nordstreams zwei Pipeline
sowie es Präsident Putin gestern
nochmals angeboten hat handeln sie
endlich im Interesse des deutschen
Volkes sonst werden sie alle irgendwo
unter irgendwann das wohlverdiente
Schicksal der FDP teilen und zugunsten
der Alternative für Deutschland
abgewählt werden vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Olaf in der Beeck hat das Wort für die
FDP-Fraktion
Olaf in der Weg ist der klimapolitische
Sprecher der Sozialdemokraten
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja das mit dem Fluch und Segen zugleich
ne was gerade der Kruse sagte ist
bemerkenswert aber sagen wir da nicht zu
und täglich grüßt uns wieder das
Murmeltier schon wieder öffnen Sie die
Konserve
und dürfen wir uns hier im Plenum des
Deutschen Bundestages mit ihren
halbgaren und wenig kreativen Antrag zur
Strom- und gassperren auseinandersetzen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Linksfraktion in der Tat sorgen sich
viele viele Menschen wegen der hohen
Strom- und Gaspreise beim Gegensatz zu
ihnen nehmen wir die Sorgen ernst und
machen uns nicht mit solaren Ideen wie
Sie ein schlanken Fuß das System das
System einfache Lösung für komplexe
Probleme hat noch nie funktioniert und
es wird auch hier nicht funktionieren
lassen Sie uns doch mal über den Kern
des Problems reden die Preise im
Stromsektor steigen vor allem weil das
angebotsstark zurückgegangen ist dass
sie als Linksfraktion vom
Marktwirtschaft Mechanismen wenig
verstehen wundert mich nicht aber jedem
sollte klar sein dass bei sinkendem
Angebot aber nicht ähnlich sinkender
Nachfrage der Preis steigt doch statt
wie sie an den Symptomen herumzudocktern
müssen wir den Kern das Problems angehen
und da ist die Lösung vor allem
angebotausweiten und zwar so schnell wie
es geht
wir brauchen
wir brauchen jetzt so viel Energie wie
möglich um auch wirklich die Preise zu
senken welche Ideen haben sie dazu in
den Anträgen keinen einzigen was sie
wollen ist der Umgang mit
Mangelwirtschaft statt diese im Kern zu
bekämpfen aber sei es drum das liegt
wohl eher in der Tradition ihrer Partei
damit Mangelwirtschaft da haben sie
Erfahrungen den Menschen in Deutschland
ist dabei früher wie heute nicht
geholfen deswegen ist die Antrag auch
reinster Populismus denn wer versucht
Krise mit einfachen und primitiven
Lösungen zu begegnen der streut den
Menschen Sand in die Augen wenn wir die
Knappheit und damit die Steigerung der
Preise wirklich in den Begriff bekommen
wollen dann brauchen wir neben einer
steigenden Angebot weitere Instrumente
und die kommen mir es ist doch absoluter
Blödsinn dass wir die Menschen
Unternehmen alleine lassen würden wir
haben insgesamt
Liebe Kollege klebe gerade schon betont
hat insgesamt 100 Milliarden Euro auf
den Weg gebracht damit ist der
menschliche Unternehmen ganz konkret
geholfen und dabei bleibt es ja nicht
denn jetzt werden 200 Milliarden Euro
zusätzlich zur Verfügung gestellt die
als Abwehrschirm die deutsche Wirtschaft
und die Verbraucher entlasten werden und
wir verteilen das Geld nicht mit der
Gießkanne sondern wir schaffen gezielte
Entlastung im Gegensatz zu Ihnen legen
wir Wert darauf dass dieses Geld
sinnvoll eingesetzt wird und eine
nachhaltige gaspreisbremse kommen wird
das geschieht durch die
gaspreiskommission in der ausgewiesene
Experten setzen natürlich kann man auch
wie sie kurz vor Feierabend ein Antrag
aus der Schublade holen den man ja
sowieso jede Wahlperiode bringt wir
hingegen handeln da eher
verantwortungsvoll ja liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir befinden uns nicht nur
in einer der schwersten Krisen in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik nein es
ist energiekrieg den Russland gegen die
freie Welt führt und deswegen
und deswegen werden wir es durch den
Winter schaffen ohne das Unternehmen
ihren Betrieb einstellen müssen oder
Menschen zu Hause keinen Strom oder Gas
mehr haben dafür stehen die
Regierungsfraktionen in diesem Haus und
darauf können sich auch die Menschen in
unserem Land verlassen vielen Dank
war das meine Damen und Herren von der
SPD ich habe mal nachgeschaut aber in
der Tat ist er zwar norddeutscher aber
kommt aus Luckenwalde ist dort zumindest
geboren in Brandenburg ich hätte den
Namen wahrscheinlich noch nördlicher
angesiedelt denkt sehr ungewöhnlich der
nächste Redner oberbürgerinnen ist jetzt
bendberg von der SPD sie haben die ganze
Zeit davon gesprochen dass die
Daseinsvorsorge im Mittelpunkt stehen
muss das tut das PCK ist übereignet
worden reden ist gekauft worden die
lng-ports werden gebaut Gas wurde direkt
gekauft das ist Daseinsvorsorge und von
der rechten Seite kam nur der Staat
hätte nichts gemacht wir sind
handlungsfähig geworden wir hatten
vorher keinen Überblick darüber was
überhaupt an Gas und Strommarkt los war
heute ist der Gaspreis am Spotmarkt
wieder unter 100 Euro gefallen das ist
ein Erfolg dieser Bundesregierung ein
Erfolg der erfolgreichen Einkaufspolitik
und das bringt uns für diesen Winter auf
die richtige Spur
und natürlich soll niemand Sorge haben
dass es in der Wohnung kalt wird oder
man im Dunkeln sitzt auch dann nicht
wenn man mit der Strom- und Gasrechnung
nicht hinterher kommt der Bundeskanzler
Scholz hat gesagt niemand wird
zurückgelassen und schon gar nicht in
der größten Krise seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg meine Damen und Herren deshalb
ist es wichtig dass wir Schutzplanken an
verschiedenen Stellen aufbauen die erste
Schutzplanke ist wir bauen die
erneuerbaren Energien massiv aus Strom
aus Wind Strom aus Sonne Gas aus
Biomasse Schranken die den Ausbau stören
bauen wir ab zwar nach und nach aber mit
allerhöchster Geschwindigkeit alles was
an grüner Energie ins Netz kann muss ins
Netz und das Netz muss vor allem
erweitert werden darum beschleunigen wir
den Ausbau niebkanten Ausmaß und diese
Ausbau und diese Beschleunigung das ist
soziale Politik das verstehen sie nicht
aber ich erkläre gern warum zum einen
Bremsen wir den Klimawandel was unseren
Kindern und Kindeskindern zugute kommt
damit Fluten und Brände im Sommer nicht
der Standard werden und zum anderen
schaffen wir wer und Arbeitsplätze hier
in Deutschland von 19 von 2019 bis 21
hat sich die Zahl der Beschäftigten im
Bereich der Erneuerbaren um 30.000
erhöht und das obwohl die Windenergie
leidet und Stellenabbau ist aber gerade
diese Diskrepanz zeigt was dafür eine
Dynamik im Markt ist und mit konkreten
Ausschreibungskriterien für die offshore
Windkraft werden wir die Wertschöpfung
in Deutschland weiter stärken ganz
konkret für den fachkräftemachwuchs weil
wir das da reingeschrieben haben das ist
ein Gesetz meine Damen und Herren das
brauchen die um an den Ausschreibungen
teilzunehmen und das schafft gut
bezahlte Arbeit hier bei uns direkt vor
Ort
und ein weiterer Vorteil der
Erneuerbaren durch den Ausbau senken wir
den Strom und Gaspreis denn mehr
windsonne Biogas im System desto weniger
Erdgas brauchen wir das heißt günstige
Preise für alle die zweite Schutzplanke
ist jetzt wo es harte Fahrt kommt
spannen wir natürlich eine Schutzschirm
auf der kurzfristig trotz aller
Unterstützung nicht in der Lage ist die
Rechnung für Strom und Heizung zu zahlen
soll sich nicht sorgen unser Ziel ist
niemand soll seine Wohnung verlieren
oder eine Gas- und Stromsperre fürchten
müssen weil es in der aktuellen
Situation etwas engen wird und wir
werden hier die Anpassung vornehmen
eins ist für uns dabei immer klar der
Schutz der Mieterin muss immer
einhergehen mit einem ausreichender
Schutz von Vermietern von
Genossenschaften und Stadtwerken denn
die meisten Vermieter sind die kleinen
die ihre Wohnung als Altersvorsorge
vermieten und die Stadtwerke können am
allerwenigsten dafür die dritte
Schutzplanke ist damit es gar nicht dazu
kommt erst das Strom und Gasrechnung
nicht gezahlt werden können müssen wir
die preisbremsen auf den Weg bringen es
ist gut dass die Ampel die nötigen
Mittel für eine gaspreisbremse frei
gemacht hat damit schaffen wir die
Sicherheit für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und auch für die Unternehmen denn
besonders geringe und mittelverdiener
treffen die hohen Preise hart und eine
Umfrage der Hans-Böckler-Stiftung hat
gezeigt dass bereits die Hälfte der
Erwerbstätigen mit einem
Haushaltseinkommen von unter 2000 Euro
netto jetzt schon genötigt sind weniger
Lebensmittel einzukaufen hungern
umzuheizen darf es in einem Bereichen
Land wie Deutschland nicht geben meine
Damen und Herren
die Preisgrenzen für Strom und Gas
bedeuten auch in durchatmen für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger von denen viele
Fragen wie soll ich die hohen Kosten
stemmen wir haben das gerade im
Tagespunkt vorher gehabt wir verdoppeln
das Wohngeld und steigern die Zahl der
Berechtigten von 600.000 auf 2 Millionen
das ist ein riesengroßer Schritt aber
der gesenkte Gaspreis hilft auch den
Unternehmen denn das bedeutet
Planungssicherheit und eine Perspektive
für die Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer das ist wichtig für die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unserer Wirtschaft
den Erhalt unseres Wirtschaftsstandortes
und damit tausende Arbeitsplätze denn
gerade die kleineren haben
Direktverträge und finden kaum noch neue
Lieferanten für Strom und Gas und das
trifft konkret die Mittelständler
besonders in Schleswig-Holstein zum
Beispiel denn dort arbeiten 94 von 100
Leuten in den kleinen und mittleren
Unternehmen
das und die ganze Wirtschaft kommt
übrigens in ihrem Antrag gar nicht vor
wir müssen sogar noch viel mehr tun um
unsere Wirtschaft zu unterstützen denn
diese Wirtschaft bezahlt das Essen und
Trinken der Menschen die in den
Wohnungen leben die sie jetzt schützen
wollen
und das wissen wir und darum ist die
gaspreisbremse ein erstes Kernelement
nicht das letzte die
expertenexpertenkommission hat Anfang
der Woche gute Vorschläge gemacht aber
es ist ein Zwischenbericht nicht die
Forderung der Bundesregierung wie sie es
ja aufgestellt haben und wir entwerfen
jetzt im parlamentarischen Prozess die
Lösung dazu meine Damen und Herren
Deutschland ist ein starker Sozialstaat
in dem diskutiert und gerungen wird es
wird aber nicht immer gleich gestritten
und es kommt im Endeffekt ein
Schutzschirm heraus der die
Transformation unserer Wirtschaft
schützt und die Folgen dieses
Wirtschaftskrieges lindert der gegen uns
geführt wird wir finden die Lösung
tatsächlich im Kampf oder per Befehl wie
in anderen KollegInnen sondern im Dialog
das passt nicht allen aber es ist die
beste aller Lösung und darauf können wir
wirklich stolz sein vielen Dank
von der SPD er ist im vergangenen Jahr
in den Bundestag eingezogen hat den
gustav-wahlkreis Segeberg stormarn-mitte
gewonnen gegen den amtierenden
der von der CDU seit 2002 diesen
Wahlkreis Inhalte Ottilie klein jetzt
für die cdu/csu
stellen die Menschen in diesen Tagen
ihre Heizung an die meisten tun es mit
Unbehagen vielen offenen Fragen und
Unsicherheiten deshalb ist es richtig
dass der vorliegende Antrag den Blick
auch auf die soziale Dimension der Krise
länger denn die warme Wohnung droht auch
immer mehr zur sozialen Frage zu werden
eins ist aber auch klar die Kollegin
weiß hat das von uns schon
ausgeführt mit diesem unkonkreten Antrag
mit diesem Dreizeiler der Linken lassen
sich die aktuellen Herausforderungen der
Krise nicht lösen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Lagen
der wir uns befinden ist dramatisch
ich habe Angst
das Schreiben die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
uns Abgeordneten in den letzten Wochen
immer wieder und in solchen Momenten
frage ich mich was antworten Sie
eigentlich sie Abgeordnete von der
ampelfraktion den Bürgern you never walk
alone also ich hoffe ihnen fällt noch
etwas besseres ein denn warme Worte
heizen keine Wohnung
die Wahrheit ist vieler Menschen fühlen
sich von der Bundesregierung alleine
gelassen da sind die Rentnerinnen und
Rentner die bis vor kurzem in den
entlastungspaketen einfach ausgespart
wurden ein Viertel unserer Bevölkerung
Menschen die oft über wenig Ersparnisse
verfügen oder sich nicht einfach so mal
eben was dazu verdienen können und
deswegen sagen wir es ist gut dass die
ampelregierung jetzt auf unsere Kritik
hin reagiert und auch Rentnern und
Studierenden eine energiepauschale
gewähren will schlecht dass es so lange
gedauert hat
da sind jene 30 Millionen Menschen die
das Pech haben eine Gasheizung in ihrer
Wohnung zu haben sie hätten mit der
unsozialen gasumlage fast ein
doppelwumms auf Ihre Heizkostenrechnung
bekommen warum weil der ampelregierung
nichts besseres eingefallen ist als die
Rettung der Energieversorgung unseres
Landes einseitig auf die Gaskunden
abzuwälzen gut dass sie Herr Habeck
unserem Appell buchstäblich in letzter
Minute gefolgt sind und ihre unsoziale
gasumlage gestoppt haben schlecht dass
es so lange gedauert hat
da sind die kleinen Betriebe die
Handwerker die nicht wissen wie sie die
Gehälter zahlen sollen weil die
Energiekosten schon jetzt nicht mehr zu
stemmen sind bis heute ist unklar wie
die ampelregierung Arbeitsplätze bei
kleinen und mittleren Unternehmen
erhalten möchte gut und das möchte ich
an der Stelle auch sagen dass unser
grüner Wirtschaftsminister wenigstens
eingesehen hat dass man nicht einfach
folgenlos aufhören kann zu produzieren
schlecht dass es so lange gedauert hat
denn die Insolvenzen sind bereit zum ein
Drittel im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
gestiegen
und da sind die Familien mit Kindern
Alleinerziehende Menschen im
Niedriglohnsektor die sich mit den
Energiepreisen alleine gelassen fühlen
da sind die sozialen Einrichtungen die
gemeinnützigen Vereine die Krankenhäuser
die nicht wissen wie sie durch den
Winter kommen deswegen ist es jetzt so
wichtig auch ein sozialen Hilfsfonds
aufzusetzen der explizit auch die
sozialen Dienstleister mit einbezieht
damit nicht jene alleingelassen werden
die gerade in der Krise stark belastet
sind auch das empfiehlt im übrigen die
Expertenkommission
an dieser Stelle ein ganz herzlichen
Dank übrigens an die 20-köpfige
Kommission die innerhalb von 48 Stunden
aufholen musste was die ampelfraktionen
einem halben Jahr hier an Energie
verschwendet haben während sie sich im
oppositionsmodus an 16 Jahren
erfolgreicher unionsgeführter
Regierungsarbeit abkämpften
wir als Union lassen die Menschen nicht
alleine unsere Lösungsvorschläge liegen
seit mehreren Monaten auf dem Tisch nur
um einige zu nennen bürgerbasispreis
einführen 1.000 Euro Soforthilfen für
Haushalte im unteren einkommensdrittel
Hilfspakete für kleine und mittlere
Unternehmen und natürlich und vor allem
alle zur Verfügung stehenden
Produktionskapazitäten nutzen auch die
Kernkraft
und wir haben das heute ja auch schon
von meiner Kollegin gehört Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz rühmt sich ja ganz gerne
damit auf Krisen vorbereitet zu sein und
alles schon vorher gewusst zu haben erst
vorgestern sagte er dass sich das
Kanzleramt angeblich seit Dezember
letzten Jahres auf eine mögliche
Energiekrise vorbereitet und trotzdem
stehen wir hier und Mitte Oktober liegen
immer noch keine Vertrauen schaffenden
beschlussfähigen Lösungen vor wir als
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion von Sie
deshalb auf endlich aus der Beratung
herauszufinden und Führung in der Krise
zu beweisen die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
haben ein Anrecht darauf dass die
Bundesregierung jetzt handelt das
Beschwören von Fußballhymnen reicht
jedenfalls nicht vielen Dank
Ottilie klein war das Abgeordnete der
Unionsfraktion unter anderem Mitglied im
Ausschuss für Arbeit und Soziales und
damit kommen wir zur vorletzten Rednerin
in dieser Debatte das ist Hanna
Steinmüller für Bündnis 90 die Grünen im
Deutschen Bundestag
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Mieterinnen und Mieter stehen gerade
extrem unter Druck das wissen wir
steigende Energiepreise steigende
Lebensmittelpreise und wenn es schlecht
läuft und man einen indexmietvertrag hat
auch noch stark steigenden Mietkosten
die Bundesregierung und wir als
Parlament versuchen Mieterinnen und
Mieter in dieser schwierigen Zeit zu
unterstützen für uns ist klar niemand
soll in kalten oder im Dunklen in seiner
Wohnung sitzen oder die Wohnung im
schlimmsten Fall verlieren
zu den Strom und Gaspreisen da sind
Minister Habeck und sein Haus und Steffi
Lemken und ihr Haus bereits im Gespräch
und arbeiten an einer Regelung
mindestens genauso richtig wichtig ist
es aber auch
zielgerichte zu unterstützen damit erst
gar keine energierückstände entstehen
auch darüber sollten wir sprechen dafür
haben wir ein breites Maßnahmen für
Mieterinnen und Mieter geschnürt wir
werden eine heizkostenkomponente im
Wohngeld einfügen darum ging es in der
Debatte der davor ab dem ersten 23
werden zwei Millionen Haushalte in
Deutschland wohngeldberechtigt sein
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger nutzen Sie
diese Möglichkeit es gibt Online-Rechner
prüfen Sie ob auch sie Unterstützung
bekommen können und nutzen sie das
für alle Menschen die jetzt schon Welt
Wohngeld bekommen gibt es einen zweiten
einmaligen Heizkostenzuschuss für
Menschen die Wohngeld bekommen die
BAföG-berechtigt sind Ausbildungs- und
berufshilfe für einen einen
Personenhaushalt sind das 415 Euro bei
zwei Personen kommen 540 Euro zusammen
und für jede weitere Person 100 Euro
mehr wir werden ein gaspreisdecke und
ein strompreisdeckel einführen dazu gab
es wirklich umfangreiche Debatten in den
letzten Tagen und die energiepauschale
in Höhe von 300 Euro sind bereits
ausgezahlt worden auch das ist wichtig
klar ist aber auch
es ist kein Signal der Sorglosigkeit wir
tun alles um Härten abzufedern aber es
darf nicht der Eindruck entstehen dass
niemand was tun müsste das Gebot jetzt
Stunde ist das wer kann Energie sparen
sollte
was können Mieterinnen und Mieter jetzt
tun die ihre Energierichtung nicht mehr
zahlen können die Energie die
Verbraucherschutzzentralen bieten vor
Ort Beratung an auch die
Bundesnetzagentur hat Informationen
bereitgestellt nutzen Sie das und treten
Sie im Zweifelsfall mit ihren Versorgern
in Kontakt liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
ist sind extrem herausfordernden Zeiten
energie sparen ist das Gebot der Stunde
die Regierung kann ich alles
kompensieren aber besondere Härten
vermeiden das tun wir mit verschiedenen
Maßnahmen vielen Dank
Hanna Steinmüller hat hier noch einmal
die Arbeit der Regierungskoalition
verteidigt und damit kommen wir zum
letzten Redner das ist Jan Diren für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen in den demokratischen
Fraktionen die Bundesnetzagentur
berichtet dass 20 Jahr seid ihr nicht
einbezogen das im Jahr 2021 knapp
235.000 Haushalten in Deutschland der
Strom abgedreht wurde ein Vergleich in
den Städten meines Wahlkreises Moers
Krefeld Neukirchen-Vluyn leben insgesamt
weniger als
200.000 Haushalte das heißt es würde
bedeuten für alle Menschen in meinem
Wahlkreis bliebe morgens das Licht aus
die Wohnung dunkel und kalt noch
häufiger als dass diese Sperren verhängt
werden wenn sie aber angedroht 2021 für
über 4 Millionen Haushalte Deutschland
über vier Millionen dass jeder zehnte
Haushalt in Deutschland es ist
selbstverständlich richtig dafür zu
sorgen dass Menschen in diesem Winter
nicht ohne Strom und Heizung dastehen
gerade jetzt gerade in diesem Winter
deshalb bin ich Ihnen dank Werte
Kollegin von den Linken dass sie die
Problematik mit ihrem Antrag hier auf
die Tagesordnung setzen gleichzeitig ist
die Sache ein bisschen verstrickter als
es auf den ersten Weg Schein mag denn
auf der anderen Seite der Kundin die
ihre Rechnung nicht bezahlen können
stehen die Unternehmen die ihre Rechnung
nicht bezahlt bekommen
wenn ihr Energiepreise steigen und
Rechnungen nicht bezahlt werden laufen
auch diese Unternehmen eventuell auf
eine Zahlungsunfähigkeit hin uns hier
stellt das von politisches Dilemma weil
das auf die Alternative hinausläuft das
entweder reihenweise Stadtwerke und
damit die Daseinsvorsorge zusammenbricht
oder so viele Menschen in Deutschland
kalten und Dunkeln sitzen bleiben liebe
Kolleginnen mit der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse reagieren wir jetzt auf
dieses Dilemma denn mit ihr wollen wir
dafür sorgen dass einerseits die
Menschen in Deutschland ihre Rechnung
bezahlen können und andererseits sperren
in diesem Winter verhindert werden
jetzt äußern manche die Sorge diese
gaspreisbremse könnte unbeabsichtigt die
Folge haben den freien Markt
einzuschränken
die freie Preisbildung am Markt zu
wenden diese Sorge kann ich ihnen nehmen
das wird keine unbeabsichtigte Folge
sein das ist genau das worum es uns
dabei geht es geht genau darum in die
freie Preisbildung am Markt einzugreifen
weil der freie Markt die freie
Preisbildung am Markt uns ja immer und
immer wieder vor dieses Dilemma stellt
entweder steigen die Preise so weit dass
die Leute ihre Rechnung nicht bezahlen
können oder die Unternehmen
die wir so dringend brauchen um unsere
Grundbedürfnisse zu befriedigen brechen
zusammen auf dem einen oder anderen Weg
kommen wir so zum selben Ergebnis wir
schaffen es nicht unsere
Grundbedürfnisse zu denken
ein Markt aber
mit dem wir nicht dafür sorgen können
dass wir auch nur unsere
Grundbedürfnisse befrieden befriedigen
können das ist ein Markt der nicht
funktioniert und es muss auch nicht so
sein es muss ja nicht so sein dass
Unternehmen mit der Versorgung von
Grundbedürfnissen Strom Heizung Wasser
wohnen Profit machen während die
Menschen ihre Grundbedürfnisse nicht
befriedigen können weil sie ihre
Rechnung nicht mehr zahlen können und es
sollte auch nicht so sein bei dem Großen
und Ganzen mag das ja noch so
einigermaßen aufgehen aber zu welchen
Problemen das immer und immer wieder
führt sehen wir in Krisen wie dieser und
wir sehen das gerade am Beispiel der
Strom und gassperre
deshalb liebe Kolleginnen ist die
gaspreisbremse über die wir gerade
diskutieren so viel mehr als nur ein
Instrument das dafür sorgt dass die
Menschen ihre Rechnung bezahlen können
die Diskussion um die gaspreisbremse
jetzt gerade markiert die Einsicht dass
wir nicht blind dem freien Spiel des
Marktes vertrauen können wenn es darum
geht unsere Grundbedürfnisse zu decken
und sie markiert die Einsicht dass wir
genau dieses System ändern müssen um das
besser hinzukriegen dafür zu sorgen dass
Menschen in warmen Wohnungen sitzen
Strom Gas versorgen haben und ihre
Grundbedürfnisse befriedigen können das
ist die eigentliche Aufgabe von der wir
gerade stehen gehen wir sie an vielen
Dank
die Aussprache und wir kommen zur
Abstimmung über die Beschlussempfehlung
des Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und
Energie zu dem Antrag der Fraktion Die
Linke mit dem Titel Strom und gassperren
verbieten der Ausschuss empfiehlt in
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache 38 53 den Antrag der Fraktion
Die Linke auf Drucksache 2686 abzulehnen
die Fraktion DIE LINKE hat hierfür
namentliche Abstimmung verlangt und die
erfolgt jetzt gleich in der westlobby
ich bitte allerdings die Abgeordneten im
Saal noch sitzen zu bleiben da noch
weitere Abstimmungen zu Überweisungen
und die abschließenden Beratung ohne
Aussprache folgen und da eben diese
Beratung wie Katrin Göring-Eckardt
gerade angekündigt hat ohne diese
Abstimmung ohne Beratung stattfinden
werden wollen wir dann lieber die Zeit
nutzen Sie über andere wichtige
Neuigkeiten zu informieren natürlich
kommen wir aber zum Bundestag wieder
zurück wenn es weitergeht denn da wird
es äußerst pikante zugehen vor zwei
Tagen ist nämlich ein Buch erschienen
die Akte Scholz der Kanzler das Geld und
die Macht und der geht es wieder einmal
um den Warburg Steuerskandal denn in
diesem Buch wird beschrieben das Kanzler
Olaf Scholz nicht wie bisher bekannt
sehr wohl Erinnerungen hat an die
Treffen mit der Hamburger Warburg Bank
und deswegen hat die Unionsfraktion eine
Aktuelle Stunde beantragt wie gesagt
wenn es soweit ist dann kommen wir hier
wieder live in den Deutschen Bundestag
zurück aber jetzt erst einmal gebe ich
ab zum Studio zu Stefan Kul